you might think that a metal gear game
without hideo kojima is the end of the
world and in this case you're sort of
right I'm Tony and this is your
apocalyptic gamespot news update metal
gear survive takes place immediately
after ground zeroes soldiers from mother
base are sucked into a random wormhole
and sent to an alternate timeline it
looks a bit like the end of the world
with torn up structures all across a
desert and then the headless zombie show
up this is a 4 player co-op survival
game where you'll be wielding crazy
weapons beyond the usual pistols and
rifles that snake would use developer
konami also stresses that the game will
feature the series trademark stealth
mechanics metal gear survive is coming
to ps4 xbox one and pc in 2017 konami
said it will not be a sixty-dollar game
but that it will be priced more like
ground zeroes which costs thirty dollars
at launch there will definitely be more
trailers and information before Metal
Gear survive drops and to keep up with
all of it you're already in the right
place